بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد اما بعد فالدرس
موصول
حول
الفصل الذي
يختص بهجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من
زاد المعاد
من هدي خير العباد
للامام القيم ابن قيم الجوزيه شمس الدين
رحمه الله تعالى
يقول ثم مضى وابو بكر يعني مضى النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم ومعه ابو بكر الى غار ثور
فدخل
وضرب العنكبوت على بابه
وكان قد استاجرا ابن اوريقط الليث
قوله وضرب العنكبوت على بابه
لو راجعنا هذه
النقطه
وبحثنا عن اسناد هذا الخبر
فاننا لا نجد له اسنادا
ذكره كثير من اصحاب السير
والمؤرخين
ومنهم ابن اسحاق رحمه الله
وبالتالي ابن هشام في اختصاره
وتهذيبه على سيره ابن هشام اسيره ابن
اسحاق محمد ابن اسحاق رحمه الله تعالى
ولا يوجد لهذا الخبر اسناد
لان كما ذكرنا سابقا
محمد بن اسحاق رحمه الله العالم الحافظ
الفذ كتب والف سيرته باسانيده
لكن
افتقد هذا الكتاب
جاء بعده ابنه هشام
رحمه الله
واختصر هذا الكتاب
ومن جراء اختصاره حذف غالب الاسانيد
وانما يقول قال ابن اسحاق قال ابن اسحاق
قال ابن اسحاق
وهذا شيء لا باس به خاصه في مساله التاريخ
لان الروايات التي تختص بالتواريخ كثير
منها لا تنبني عليها احكام
وانما هي تذكر ويستانس بها واذا كان ما
فيها شيء منكر فانها تحكى
لان العلماء رحمهم الله تعالى
تساهلوا
وتماشوا مع هذه الروايات
وان ضعف السند
هذه مساله ينبني ينبغي
التفرقه فيها
يعني مثلا
اذا نظرنا الى صنيع العلماء
فانه يتكامل عندنا صوره
عن ما يغلب على الظن انه صحيح من الاسانيد
والحسن والضعيف
لكن العلماء خاصه الائمه
والمحققين منهم
فانهم
يختلفوا
شده الشرط في اسانيد
لا ترفع الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يعني مثلا اذا اردت
ان اروي حديثا عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال رسول الله او فعل رسول الله او
اقر رسول الله هذه
اكثرها من الوحي
وما ينطق عن الهوى ان هو الا وحي يوحى
فهذا الوحي
ينبني عليه احكام ينبني عليه نتائج وفهوم
فينبغي ان نتشدد وان يكون لنا شرط قوي
في تصحيح هذه الروايات اذا كان حدا ساقط
من الاسناد غير مذكور او كان في تدليس او
كان في شبهه فان العلماء
لا يرون هذه الاحاديث
او لا يصححون هذه الاحاديث
لكن اذا كان الخبر منسوب الى صحابي مثلا
فان هذا الشرط
يقل لا يكون شده الشرط في قول الصحابي نفس
شده الشرط الذي يكون فيه قول الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
المساله اسهل لماذا لان هذا يكون غالبه من
الراي الا اذا كان شيئا
له حكم رافع فانه له حكم تصحيح الحديث
المرفوع الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ثم اذا كان الخبر منسوب الى تابعي
فالشرط لا يكون نفس الشرط
الذي هو شديد في تصحيح حديث رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
اذا كان في ضعف يسير في الاسناد والخبر
منسوب الى تابعي ما في مشكله يحكونه
ويقولون قال فلان كذا وهذا كثير في روايات
التفسير
قال ابن عباس كذا قالب بن مسعود كذا قرا
فلان بالقراءه الشاذه كذا لا باس
يستانس بهذه
وهكذا وهلم جره
وكذلك اذا جاء في السير او في الملاحم او
في
التفسير هذه الروايات الغالب فيها ان
اسانيدها يكون فيها الضعيف والمعضل ويكون
فيه التدليس ويكون فيه الارسال ولا باس
العلماء يذكرون ذلك
فابن القيم رحمه الله ذكر هذا الخبر
وبعض العلماء قال هذا ليس عليه
دليل قطعي لان الاسناد فيه كذا او الاسناد
محذوف نعم لكن لا ينبني عليه احكام
وانا رايت بعض الناس يقرا في السيره
ويجد ان العنكبوت ضرب ببيته على غار ثور
فيقولون يكره ان يقتل العنكبوت شفت عنكبوت
دشرها ليش لانها
سترت على النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هذا
كلام لا يقوله العلماء وانما هذا الشيء
متداول بين بعض الناس وكذلك مساله الحمامه
هو ما ذكر الحمامه لان اضعف حالا من مساله
العنكبوت لكن
ذكر اصحاب السير ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم دخل
وابو بكر غار ثور فضرب العنكبوت على باب
الغار وجاءت الحمامه
وجعلت عشها على الباب فلما جاء المشركون
الى غار ثور وهم
يبحثون عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وصاحبه الصديق
فانهم وجدوا بيت هذا العنكبوت وقالوا كيف
يدخلوا الغار وهذا البيت موجود لو دخل
الغار كان هوتك هذا البيت كذلك نفس الشيء
بالحمامه كان هربت الحمامه وطارت
فهذه مساله الله اعلم قد يكون
ما فيه مشكله انه الانسان يذكر هذه
المسائل لانها ذكرها العلماء
واستانسوا بها في كتبهم لكن من ناحيه
الروايه عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا هذه بعضها وكثير منها ما الها روايات
ولا الها اسانيد وهي مسائل يعني
توارثها العلماء حكايه بدون ازمه بدون
اسانيد ولا باس بذكرها
لانها غير منسوبه الى الوحي
يعني مساله العنكبوت فعل كذا والحمامه
فعلت كذا هذا غير منسوب الى الوحي
ونجد هذا كثيرا في كثير من الاخبار
المتداوله المعروفه
لدى المسلمين لدى عامه المسلمين فمثلا
لما جاء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في فتح
مكه
ودخل الكعبه
وصلى في نواحيها ثم خرج فوجد القوم صفوفا
افواجا بين يديه ينتظرون قوله وقضاءه فيهم
يامر بقتلهم الاليامر بتهجيرهم ما شابه
ذلك مما هو شان الفاتحين
فخرج النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اليهم وقال ماذا تروني ماذا ترون اني فاعل
بكم
قالوا
كريم ابن كريم معروف القصه
ويقال لهؤلاء الذين اسلموا في هذه
المرحله من دعوه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بانه مطلقاء اذهبوا فانتم الطلقات هذه
الروايه فيها ضعف من ناحيه الاسناد ذكرها
ابن اسحاق رحمه الله ونقلها ابن هشام عنه
لكن هي
هي مشهوره متداوله بين العلماء ولا باس في
حكايتها فان الظن يغلب على ان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال هذا ولا ياتي هذا
الخبر بحكم جديد
يعني لو كان في مساله لا توجد في عموم
القران ولا في خصوص احكام القران ولا في
السنه وروايه ضعيفه تقول هذا حلال او هذا
حرام حينئذ لا نتوقف نقول لا بد من صحه
الاسناد وقوه الاسناد
لكن مثل هذه الاخبار فلا باس بها بعض
الشباب او بعض الطلاب يتشددون في هذه
المسائل ولا باس فيها لذلك ذكرها ابن
القيم رحمه الله يقول وكان قد استاجرا ابن
اريقت الليثي كان مشركا لكنه كان ماهرا في
الطريق يعرف الطرق الى
مختلف البلدان والصحراء صعبه بمكان
الذهاب والاياب فيها والسفر فيها اذا ضاع
الانسان فانه او اذا ضل الطريق لان
الانسان يمشي في الصحراء على مراحل
والناس يعرفون مواقع الابار
فهو يمشي مثلا ما في قرى ما في شيء لكن في
بئر معين هنا فياتون الى هذا البير
ويسافرون بين هذه الابار حتى يصلوا الى
المكان الذي
يبغونه فاذا ظل الانسان الطريق
وما اندل الى هذا البير يهلك
في الصحف
الماهر بالطريق لابد من الدليل خاصه في
هذه الاسفار فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
استاجر ابن اريقت الليثي وكان مشركا لكنه
كان امينا على هذا
العلماء ذكروا ان
استعمال خدمات
الكافر في مهنته وهو امين في مهنته فان
هذا جائز يعني مثلا لو الانسان ذهب الى
الدكتور
والطبيب يحكي له انك
لا ينبغي لك ان تصوم فان هذا يضر بصحتك
وهو كافر غير مسلم
لكنه امين في مهنته فانه ينبني على قوله
احكام شرعيه يجوز له يجوز للمسلم ان يصدر
عن راي الطبيب وبعض العلماء اشترط طبيبين
لكن القصه
معناها ان الانسان اذا اعتمد على غير
المسلم في
تخصصه وهو امين في ذلك امين في مهنته فان
هذا لا باس به يقول ابن القيم وكان ماهرا
بالطريق وهو على دين قومه يعني على دين
المشركين
وامناه على ذلك او وامناه على ذلك وسلم
اليه
راحلتيهما دخل هذا الغار
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم قال له انطلق
عد بعد ان يبرد الطلب
ونحن نبقى ننتظرك هانا في هذا الغار
وامناه على ذلك
قال وواعداه الغار بعد ثلاث يعني بعد ثلاث
ثلاث ليالي وجدت قريش في طلبهما واخذوا
معهم القاف حتى انتهوا الى باب الغار
وكان عامر ابن فهيره يرعى عليهما غنما
لابي بكر ومكث فيه ثلاثا حتى خمدت عنهما
نار الطلب
وهما في هذا الغار
اسماء بنت ابي بكر رضي الله عنها
كانت تاتيهما بطعامهما
حتى عاد اليهما ابن اريقط قال ثم جاءهما
ابن اريقط بالراحلتين فارتحل
واردف ابو بكر عامر ابن فهير وسار الدليل
امامهما وعين الله تصحبهما
واسعاده
يقول رحمه الله ولما ايس المشركون منهما
جعلوا لمن جاء به ماديته كل واحد منهما
يعني جائزه على من جاء به بهما او باحدهما
فجد الناس في الطلب والله غالب على امره
فلما مروا بحي بني مدلج
بصر بهم رجل من الحي
فقال لهم لقد رايت بالساحل اسوده ما اراها
الا محمدا واصحابه
ففطن سراقه
يعني جاء احد القوم وقال انا رايت
اثنين ماشيين ابعاد مش شايف الا السواد
وانا بظن هذا محمد وابو بكر
صلى الله عليه وسلم ورضي الله عن الصديق
فسراق ابن مالك المدلجي
فاطن لهما واراد ان ياخذ هذه الجائزه
فيهما والديه
قال فاراد ان يكون له الظفر خاصه
بدال ما هذه الديه
تتفرق عليه وعلى من اعانه على القبض
عليهما سراقه
يعني
انسحب من بين القوم ولم يحكي لاحد لانه
يريد ان يظفر الجائزه لنفسه
وقد سبق له من الظفر ما لم يكن في حسابه
فقال بل هما فلان وفلان وخرج في طلب حاجه
لهما
يعني هذا الذي جاء من القوم قال رايت
اثنين
ماشيين ولا اظنهما الا
محمدا وابا بكر
فسراق
بدال ما يحمل معه جماعته
اشده
قبيلته ويذهب
ويقبض عليهما وبعدين الجائزه من قريش بدها
ايش تتفرق عليهم جميعا ويكون لكل واحد سهم
فلم يرد سراق ذلك اراد ان يظفر بالجائزه
كامله لنفسه
فماذا صنع قال لهذا الذي جاء بالخبر قال
لا ابو فلان وفلان هذا مش محمد هذا فلان
وفلان خرج لحاجه لهما وبعدين انسحب بلطافه
وذهب للقبض عليهما ثم مكث قليلا يعني
سراقه ثم قام فدخل قبائه وقال لخادمه
اخرجي او اخرجي بالفرس من وراء الخباء
وموعدك وراء الاكمه الاكمه يعني اللي هي
المكان المرتفع يعني احنا بنقول كلها
هذه الاكمه
مكان مرتفع من الارض وقال لخادمته خذ
الفرس
واطلعي ما تخلي حدا يشوفك وموعدك بلاقيك
وين وراء الاكمه
يعني وراء التله
ثم اخذ رمحه
وخفض عاليه يخط به الارض حتى ركب فرسه
فلما قروا منهم
وسمع قراءه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وهو
لا يلتفت وابو بكر يكثر الالتفات
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ماشي ولا يتلفت
ابو بكر خايف على الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم فهو اكثر من الالتفات خايف حدا
يشوفهم
يعني يؤذي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
ابو بكر يا رسول الله هذا سراقه
قد
رهقنا يعني ادركنا
فدعى عليه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فساخت يدا فرسه في الارض
وهذا الخبر موجود في صحيح البخاري كان
الفرس ماشي
ويدى الفرس ساخه في الارض
وان رمى سراق عن ظهر الفرس فقال قد علمت
ان الذي اصابني بدعائكما
فادعوا لي
ولكما علي ان ارد الناس عنكما
وفي خبر او في هذه الروايه عند الامام
البخاري هذا كان اكثر من مره
يعني هجم عليهما فدعا النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
فساخت يدا الفرس في الارض
وانكب عنها ثم
مره ثانيه وثالثه في بعض الاخبار حتى ايس
وعلم ان ذلك مش يعني القصه هاي مش صدفه
هذا من دعاء الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
فوصل اليهما وقال قد علمت ان الذي اصابني
بدعائكما فادعوا لي او فادعوا لي
ولكما علي ان ارد الناس عنكما
فدعا له رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاطلق فرسه
وساله ان يكتب له كتابا فكتب له ابو بكر
بامره في اديم وكان معه الى يوم فتح مكه
فجاء بالكتاب
فوفي له رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقال اليوم يوم وفاء وبر كتب له ان لك كيت
وكيت طبعا الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم عرض
عليه الاسلام
صراخ ابن مالك
لما بنراجع كتب الرجال نجد ان سراق ابن
مالك محسوب في المخضرمين
والمخضرم هو ما كان بين الصحابي وبين
التابعي ايش هو المخضرم ايش الصحابي شو
المقصود من هذا الكلام
طبعا العلماء جعلوا
رواه الحديث والناس الذين جاءت الاخبار
عنهم
في كتب السير وكتب الرجال
العلماء جعلوا الناس على طبقات
فعندك الطبقه
الاولى اللي هي الصحابه وبعض العلماء فرق
بين كبار الصحابه وصغار الصحابه كبار
الصحابه
اكثرهم مابروا احاديث لنا لانهم ماتوا
وتوفاهم الله قبل
ان يطلب الحديث منهم
كان الصحابه متواجدين هذولا كبار الصحابه
الذين كانوا في سن البلوغ او اكبر من ذلك
يكون واحد عمره 20 25 30 40 50 سنه لما
بعث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم او لما هاجر
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وتوفي بعد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بقليل
هؤلاء من كبار الصحابه
صغار الصحابه
الذين اطال الله عمرهم بعد وفاه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم وهذول اكثر الصحابه روايه
للحديث عندك من صغار الصحابه مثل انس بن
مالك واثلا ابن الاسقع هؤلاء من صغار
الصحابه
كانوا صغار في وقت الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم عبد الله بن الزبير الحسن الحسين
هذول كانوا
كانوا سببه صغار لما بعث النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يعني الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
توفي عن ابن عباس وهو ابن 14 سنه يعني كان
صغير
وابن عمر نفس الشيء كان صغيرا
فهؤلاء يكونون في طبقه الصحابه طبقه صغار
الصحابه
سراق ابن مالك كان كبيرا
ولقي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بعد نبوته
وعاش الى عهد عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
لكنه لا يحسب من الصحابه بل هو محسوب من
المخضرمين او محسوب من التابعين كبار
التابعين كيف يعني كيف هو لقي الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم وليس من الصحابه العلماء
عرفوا الصحابي في المشهور الذي استقر عليه
رايه اكثر علماء الحديث
عرفوا الصحابي بمن لقي النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
مؤمنا به ومات على ذلك
لاحظوا التعريف
ما هو الصحابي يقولون من لقي النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم اللقاء حتى لو بس شافوا ما
سمع منه اشي لكنه راه ولم يسمع منه هذا
يعتبر من من الصحابه لكن بشرط وهذا الشرط
ان يكون حين لقائه رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم كان مؤمنا كان دخل في الاسلام
ثم مات على ذلك اذا ارتد بعد ذلك والعياذ
بالله لا يكون صحابيا بل مات على ذلك
الايمان
سراقه لما كانت هذه
الواقعه بينها وبين الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم وابي بكر
ودعا عليه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وكان
يطلبهما
لياخذ الجائزه او الديه
فانه لم يؤمن بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
عرض عليها الاسلام
قال
اتشهد اني رسول الله تشهد ان لا اله الا
الله فقال لا
ولكن
اعاهدك الا
اقاتلك ولا اكون مع من يقاتلونك
هذا هو الوعد الذي كان بينه وبين النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم وهذا يكفي الاسلام لم
يقصد منه
قتل واستئصال
من لم يدخل في الاسلام المقصود من الجهاد
ماذا الدفاع عن المسلمين
ومن وقف في طريق دعوه المسلمين فان هذا
يكون عليه الحرب لكن الذي
يعاهد الا يؤذي المؤمنين ولا يؤذي
المسلمين ولا يكون مع احد يقاتل المسلمين
لكن لا يدخل في الاسلام كفان الله سبحانه
وتعالى شره ما في قتال بينه
وهذا مذكور في سوره النساء على كل حال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما استمر معه في الدعوه بعد ذلك ما الزمه
ولا ارغمه ولا يحث على الاسلام فاذا لم
يسلم لا اكراه في الدين قد تبين الرشد من
الغير
فهو لم يسلم ولكنه
وعد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان يكف اذاه
وشره عن المسلمين وهذا هو المطلوب
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم تركوا وهذا
يحصل تجد هذه القصص
في الصحيحين كان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
نائما ومعلقا سيفه على شجره كانوا في غزوه
نزلوا عند بعض الشجرات
فتفرق الناس
يطلبون ظل الشجر
ونزل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عند شجره
معينه وعلق سيف وعليها الشجره ونام
والناس ناموا
فجاء احد
المشركين مر عنهم ووجده نائما فاستل سيفه
وايقظه
مشهر مشهرا السيف في وجهه الكريم عليه
الصلاه والسلام
فقال له من يمنعك مني
حين مساكتك فش بيني وبينك الا السيف مين
يمنعك مني
فقال الله
فوقع السيف من يده
ثم اخذ النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم السيف
وقال من يمنعك مني
وهذه كانت طبعا من دفاع الله سبحانه
وتعالى عنه والله يعصمك من الناس
فهذا لم يسلم
قال له اتشهد ان لا اله الا الله واني
رسول الله قال لا لكنه عاهده الا يقاتله
ولا يقاتل المسلمين ولا يكون مع احد او
قوم يقاتلونهم
تركه
فعاد الى اصحابه هذا المشرك وقال جئتكم من
عند خير الناس
يعني تصور واحد يشهر عليه السلاح وهو نايم
ويقصد الى
اذلاله وقتله وقهره ثم تنقلب الموازين
ويكون السيف بيدي
الذي كان تحت السيف قبل قليل ماذا يصنع به
اكثر الناس يقتلوا او يذل او
لكن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم تركه
فقال جئتكم من عند خير الناس
فهنا حصل نفس هذا الشيء مع سراقه سراقه
فان لقي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ما كان
مؤمنا به
سراقه اسلم بعد
بعض العلماء ذكر انه اسلم حتى في عهد عمر
يعني بعد
موت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بسنين
فهو راى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مجتمع
معه
لكنه ماذا لم يكن مسلما حين اجتماعه معه
اسلم فيما بعد
فهذا ليس من الصحابه
على حسب هذا التعريف تعريف الصحابي من لقي
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مؤمنا به ومات
على ذلك
ولقيه
لكنه حين لقائه
لم
يكن مسلما ما كان مسلما ثم اسلم فيما بعد
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر ان
كنوز
كسرى
ستوزع على المسلمين
تنفى ستنفق كنوز كسرى في سبيل الله هيك
حكى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
هذا كان شيء فوق الخيال يعني تصوروا سبحان
الله الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم جالس في
مسجده
الارض
من الحصى
والحيطان من الطين
والسقف من جريد النخل
واركان المسجد
هي من شجر النخل شيء متواضع جدا ما في
ابواب على المسجد ما في المسجد ضو في
الليل عشان هيك الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر ان
اصعب صلاتين على المنافقين ايش
فجروا العشاء لماذا لانهم كانوا ياتون في
ظلام دامس
ما بتعرف الا اللي جنبك
فكان اذا
تخلف عن صلاه العشاء صلاه الفجر ما حد
يدري ياتون في الصلاه رياء
لكن المنافق لا ياتي على صلاه الفجر لا
ياتي على صلاه العشاء لانه ما كان في نور
ولا كان في ضوء في مسجد الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم يدخل الانسان المسجد ويصطف ولا
يستطيع ان يرى من حوله او ان يعرف من جاء
ممن لم يجد
في هذا المكان المتواضع وفي هذه الحال
والعرب اجتمعوا عليه
وكانوا يمكرون به صلى الله عليه وسلم ومرت
عليه وعلى اصحابه في المدينه ايام صعبه
جدا
حتى وصل الحال انه ربط الحجر على بطنه من
ماذا من الجوع
وكان الناس يهاجرون اليه
ويكونون في
المسجد يسكنون ليس لهم شيء حتى اللباس ما
يستطيعوا يلمسه
اهل الصفه
وحتى كان يخر احدهم في الصلاه مغشيا عليه
من الجوع
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
امر النساء الا
ترفع رؤسهن من
السجود حتى يستقيم الرجال
قائمين حتى يقفوا لماذا لانه من قله
الثياب
كان المسلم يكون ساجد او الراجل يكون ساجد
وممكن شيء من عوره تظهر من الفاقه من
الفقر
كانت النساء بتصلي وراء الرجال
جاءت هذه الاوامر
وجاءت اوامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
طعام الواحد يكفي الاثنين وطعام الاثنين
يكفي الثلاثه
كانوا في جوع وكانوا في فقر شديد ومرت
عليه ايام صعبه جدا
فالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم جالس في
المسجد
يحكي لاصحابه في هذه الاحوال تصوروا هذه
الاحوال
وهو يقول لهم
سيبلغ هذا الدين ما بلغ الليل والنهار
وهو يقول في هذه الحال باصحابه
ستنفق كنوز
كسره وقيصر في سبيل الله
وهم في هذا المسجد
وهم في هذه الاحوال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يبشر
الصحابه بذلك
فهو وعد
سراق ابن مالك من كنوز كسره
اذا تركتنا وما حكيت لحدا وكفيت اذاك عني
وعن المسلمين وما قاتلتني ما كنت مع قومي
يقاتلونني
فاعدك
من كنوز كسره
وعد عجيب
فكتب له ابو بكر رضي الله عنه هذا العهد
بينه وبين الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وعاد يوم فتح مكه سراقه قال شوف ايش كتبت
لي فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
امر له
بما وعده وكذلك جاء سراقه في وقت عمر
حين هزيمه
وتمزيق
ملك كسره وسقوط ملك كسره جاءه وقال الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم وعدني من كسره كيت
وكيت
فوفى فلما جاءه يوم فتح مكه جاء بالكتاب
فوفي له رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقال اليوم يوم وفاء وبر
وعرض عليهما الزاد
والحملان فقال لا حاجه لنا به ولكن عمي
عنا الطلب
لا احد سالك وين هم احنا ماشيين
شرق اقول راحوا غربه
احنا طالعين على الجنوب قل لهم الشمال عمي
عنا الطلب
فقال قد كفيتم
ورجع فوجد الناس في الطلب قوموا في طموله
فاجو كمان
وادركهم في منتصف الطريق قبل ان يصلوا الى
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وابي بكر فجعل
سراقي يقول
قد استبرات لكم الخبر رحت تتاكدت من هذول
الاثنين اللي شفتوهم
فكان اولا نهار جاهدا عليهما واخره
حرسا لهما
وهذا من فضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ثم مر في مسيرهما
في مسيرهما ذلك
بخيمه بخيمتي ام معبد الخزاعيه وذكر القصه
والمقصود هنا وذكر القصه يعني ابن القيم
رحمه الله
وذلك لان هذا الكتاب
مختصر زاد المعاد
ويقول
ابن القيم رحمه الله قالت اسماء
ما درينا اين توجه رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم اذ اقبل رجل من الجن من اسفل
مكه
فانشد ابياتا والناس يتبعونه يسمعون صوته
وما يرونه حتى خرج من اعلاها قالت فلما
سمعنا قوله عرفنا حيث توجه رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم وان
ذهابه واتجاهه الى المدينه
وكانت كما ذكرت لكم اسماء رضي الله عنها
وهي كبيره اكبر من عائشه بكثير كانت
تاتيهما بالزاد وتاتيهما بهذه الاشياء
فلما سمعت هذا الصوت
في مكه اخذت بالاشارات فعرفت ان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم توجه الى المدينه
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقني واياكم
بما يحب ويرضى اسالوا تعالى ان يعلمنا من
كتابه ما جهلنا وان يذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وان يبارك لنا في كتابه وان يبارك لنا
فيما فيه من الذكر والايات الحكيم
نكتفي بهذا القدر ان شاء الله الله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين